so switzerland has a bill pending that
is going to give every adult in the
country 2 800 bucks a month they are
gonna vote on this shortly and they want
a basic minimum sort of living standard
for everybody and i just saw this and i
think this is kind of great now they're
a very small country far smaller than
america just to give you some
perspective their population is 7.9
million people it's like new york
it's basically like new york new york
has 8.3 million what do we have here
like 300 million something like that so
it's not we can't really compare this uh
through you know through the american
lens because obviously they're much
smaller and they can do things on a
micro level that we could never do here
i think though of the 300 million
americans i think 180 million of them
are mexicans taking our jobs that's what
i hear mexicans taking our jobs i was
going to say it's just people on the la
freeways that's right yeah
yeah exactly so all right so basically
switzerland which already has universal
health care by the way which is given to
everybody and if you're rich you do pay
a little bit of a higher premium again
seems like a pretty fair system so they
seem to be doing something good there is
there anything that we as americans can
take away from this system that's trying
to give people just sort of like a
baseline to be like okay you can live
and then go from there is there anything
we can gain from that from a system like
that uh yes i would like that i would
like twenty eight hundred dollars a
month you could buy so much hot
chocolate with that that would be a
tremendous like the good stuff like from
switzerland
right and
not swiss miss everybody would you know
like the actual everybody would get a
swiss army knife that would be good that
would be great one more one worked super
convenient
um
oh of course
i mean oh my god what else do they have
so look they have happiness ben
they have happiness um because they're
all equal look
we have the best system of everything in
this country our country is the best and
we can't learn anything from anyone else
never yeah we're exceptional i don't
know what kind of question you i don't
know what kind of america hating uh
slant you take it when you learn
something from switzerland no yeah
and their dogs and their cheese and
their stupid hot chocolate in the
packets and the skiing right and the
skiing and the incredibly hot women and
the yeah sex with strangers i don't know
that happens but i've been focusing on
that a lot yeah there's been a very real
theme i sense that that's part of it's
like you know you say it's a small
country but it's eight million people
it's not it's
right like i mean they got they have a
country and
you know uh and they of course have
strict immigration laws themselves
because otherwise if they do this you
would imagine that some neighbors in
germany and france who might be less
well-off would think well let's go to
switzerland and get the thirty four
thousand eight hundred dollars a year
right exactly did you just think that go
ahead i would just say it'd be nice to
feel comfortable month to month that
just that alone just that that fact
that'd be nice that would be nice yeah
do things like this ever make you think
that the united states actually is too
big to function because even if you look
at everything going on in congress right
now that our lives say here in
california uh with obviously a more
liberal set of beliefs than say a
congressman in
you know arkansas or something that this
guy is still voting on the things that
affect our lives when we really live
it's seemingly in another
part of the world all together it's kind
of crazy yeah it feels like that yeah
now i'm a secessionist too or something
like that i you know look i i the
state's rights don't interest me and i i
i mean i would i would have so many more
federal laws really yeah i don't think
it's because i don't think states know
what they're doing we've sort of had
this
we presuppose that the states all make
the right decisions californians made a
series of horrible decisions of course
we have this
incredibly silly system of the
referendums yeah where
uneducated people myself included i mean
i go to the polls and i'm like issue 7a
you know and oh my god i don't know
right well isn't that like prop 8's the
great example of that because it was
like people still weren't sure after
they left the booth i voted yes on prop
8 does that mean i'm for gay marriage or
against gay marriage i think it meant
you were yeah against if you voted yes
there was a lot of compelling
information that if the vote had been
for gay marriage or against gay marriage
that four gay marriage would have won
yeah um right so it's a silly way of
doing things and and and i don't think
that uh because you can do something in
one state that it seems silly to me that
you can't do it in another state yeah so
getting back to switzerland for a second
do you think all these people are just
going to stop working once you have like
just if you just had a basic amount of
money and could pretty much pay your
rent and live would you just retire with
the brie easter egg operation be over or
it would just begin no it would just
begin i would feel comfortable and i
would be able to to do the job that i
want to do yeah
i think that's the most important thing
you can actually do spend your days
doing what you want to do yeah do you
think there is some risk of like i guess
it's very anti-capitalism the idea that
you'd be given something even if it just
puts you at a baseline the capitalism
people capitalism doesn't work so people
can make thirty four thousand eight
hundred dollars a year i mean it's not
that's not that's not how it's set up
was that the math
yeah i think yeah yeah no i'm wrong
because it's 200 off 12 so it's it's
2400 less than 36 000 so it's a so it's
a 33 6. appreciate the fact i apologize
everyone 336 a year uh so no of course
it's not going to stop the desire of
people to get ahead will it stop some
people
a lot of people yeah and like you know
there's that guy that you know fox news
jumped on a couple of weeks ago that kid
in
in in here in los angeles either in
manhattan beach or maybe he was in
malibu but he was taking government
assistance right right and spending all
his money just eating pizza and surfing
surfing because that's what he wanted to
do and fox is like aha this is what the
people on the government eat
and like yeah okay you found him but but
you know what they're here the rest of
them the millions of others
what they do is they buy their food yeah
yeah so there you go i'll say this one
right to the camera not all poor people
are surfers in case uh you don't watch
uh bill erratic hey guys the reuben
report is brought to you by coupon.com
you can get up to 75 off pet toys choose
all kinds of treats and more the link is
right down below click it and use code
rr for 20 off your first purchase